hey guys
this video will probably be one of the
most important videos that i will ever
make
on my channel the day and age we live in
is just changing fast and unfortunately
there are so many kids
growing up without a father in a home
according to earthweb.com the 2021 usa
census bureau report revealed that 18.4
million children live in fatherless
households
and then even if there are a lot of kids
with their dads at home
it doesn't mean that they are good
fathers
so this video is for you dads out there
to become better fathers and also for
you boys to understand
what a real good father is supposed to
teach his son
let's not waste any more time let's get
to the video
all right guys now there are a lot of
things that a father should teach his
son to become a responsible healthy good
man adult man
that brings value to other people a
stand-up guy
i'm not going to talk about all of them
but i am going to talk about the top 10
life teachings that i received from my
father
who was
an amazing person a great father let's
start with number one
son needs to know that he will make a
lot of mistakes in his life
and he needs to learn from his mistakes
no one is perfect so you will make
mistakes and if you do make mistakes you
just have to get up again because then
you're not a failure
but if you stay down
then that means you will be a failure
you need to get up every time when life
hits you on your knees because that is
where you learn to get stronger and grow
into a healthy mature man director
steven spielberg was rejected twice by
the university of southern california
school of cinematic arts and he also
struggled with dyslexia but that did not
stop him today he has won 11 emmys three
oscars and seven globes and is one of
the most successful directors of all
time
vincent van gogh the famous painter
struggled to sell any of his paintings
in his lifetime he sold only one
painting called the red vineyard and he
sold it before his death
he thought he failed
but today after his death his paintings
are sold for over 100 million
[Music]
treat other people the way you want them
to treat you
every father needs to tell his son this
important lesson
because this life has no meaning if you
live through it being a selfish arrogant
guy
and who treat other people just like
dirt if you want to have a good life
with great friends and people that treat
you with respect it all starts with you
most of the time your action will
determine someone else's reaction
you need to get this this means that
they will treat you the way that you
treat them if you treat people like
garbage they will think of you
as garbage if you treat people with
respect they will view you as a
respectable man
albert einstein said i speak to everyone
in the same way whether he is the
garbage man or the president of the
university
always remember this never treat other
people according to who they are but
treat them according to who you are
because
respect is a reflection
of your character
take responsibility
oh man so many people today needs to
hear this and learn this because in
today's world it seems like nobody wants
to take responsibility for their own
actions son
at a young age
start to learn how to take
responsibility
for everything that you do or say
jim ron said you must take personal
responsibility you cannot change the
circumstances the seasons or the wind
but you can change yourself that is
something you have charge of you need to
learn how to live in truth so stop
blaming other people or even lying to
yourself you know not taking
responsibility for everything that you
have said that you have done own it like
a man take responsibility for everything
in your life because only then you will
be able to change everything in your
life and always remember this
you are always responsible for how you
act
no matter how you feel
be a man of integrity this is extremely
important if you are young you need to
understand this
you need to know the importance of this
it is always more important to be a man
of integrity to be a man of value than
to be a man of success
c.s lewis said integrity is doing the
right thing even when no one is watching
real men
good honest men
are men that you can trust who stand up
for what is right not just for
themselves but for all of humanity and
they are not overcome by evil but they
overcome evil with good
son
learn to work hard
there are few things worse than a lazy
guy who wants everything in life but he
doesn't have the backbone to work for it
the way of a sluggard is like a hedge of
thorns but the path of the upright is a
level highway
you know there are some people out there
who say
all men should receive the same things
in this life
well no
not if the lazy person just wants to
receive that which the hard-working man
has worked so hard for sweat and tears
waking up early in the morning sleeping
late at night
how is that fair
it's not
so son listen up
if you want to achieve
your goals in life you need to work hard
for it because if you don't
they will only stay dreams
be a gentleman
treat women with respect
it was a woman that brought you into
this world and it is a woman that will
love you and bear your children one day
and this all starts by respecting your
own mother
james merrow said a gentleman respects
every woman in his life
if you can't respect your own mother
forget about respecting your girlfriend
you can never justify immoral behavior
some people say well if it feels good
then just do it because life is short
well if you do that
then you will hurt a lot of people
including yourself
that is extremely dumb because that is
what sets us apart from animals because
animals they just do whatever they want
how they want to do it when they want to
do it
they are controlled by their emotions
that are fecal now they feel like this
now they feel like this they are
controlled by it but not us humans can
control our own emotions
we received a moral compass within us a
brain to know the difference between
right and wrong
suffolk he said rather fail with honor
then succeed by fraud
you know it takes a lifetime to build
your honor to leave a legacy
but it takes one moment to destroy it
and at the end of your life that's all
you really have it's your integrity and
your honor because that is your legacy
money
you work too hard for your money well
you're not gonna take that with you when
you die
ask yourself
what is left when your honor
is gone
kindness and gratitude is free it
doesn't hurt you one bit
just to be kind to people
it is one of the best gifts that you can
give people and it is free it costs you
nothing
this is how you build strong
relationships with people and think
about it
you don't really like to spend time with
people who are not friendly right
so why are you not friendly to other
people
scott adams said there is no such thing
as a small act of kindness
every act creates a ripple with no
logical end
and then learn to appreciate things from
a young age
appreciate everything that you have that
your parents are giving you
and learn to say thank you you know when
someone
does something for you just out of
kindness appreciate it
son you need to be able to manage your
money well
try never to get into debt and if you do
get into debt change your lifestyle so
that you'll be able to pay off your debt
as soon as possible
dave ramsey said you must gain control
over your money or the lack of it will
forever control you
you need to learn never to buy things
that you don't need with money you don't
have just to impress people
instead plan ahead work out a budget for
every month so that you will know
exactly where your money is going
instead of wondering every month like
man where did all my money go
love god and love other people this is
the most important life lesson why
because this life
is short
and it is wise to use the little time
that you do have to prepare for the one
that comes after this life that will be
forever and ever and ever
son
think carefully about where you will go
when you die many dads tell their sons
all they know about working on a car or
working on the farm
so much detail about this short
temporary world but they never prepare
them for the life that is to come
i want to tell you about a story about a
young boy growing up on a farm
his dad taught him everything to be
tough to be a farmer to raise the cattle
he told him everything about
being a farmer and then one day he got
ill
and the night before he died he wrote a
letter to his dad
he wrote
dad
bury me in the cattle pen
because that is all you have taught me
that a son should not cry
that a son should not be sad
that i should fight my own way through
this world
from life on a farm there is nothing
that someone can teach me anymore i have
learned all i needed to know from your
torn and bruised hands
but one thing
my dad
you forgot
you told me nothing about god and what
will happen when i die
and now
the time has come for me to go
and to meet him
wow
think about the reality of this
father's
how much time are you spending teaching
your son or sons daughters about things
that are just temporary how much time
are you taking to spend with them to
teach them about god how to prepare for
the life that is waiting for them after
this one
teach them to love god to have a
relationship with him and to love other
people because that will prepare him not
just for this life but also for the one
that is waiting for them
and sons if you want to know more about
god and what true love really is how to
have a relationship with god then watch
these videos here from my other channel
and i'll see you there
and always remember
life is short so don't waste yours
cheers guys